parent est un monsieur jean louis costes
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
lors du comité interministériel ruralité
du 14 septembre dernier vous aviez
affichée avec votre gouvernement tout
l'intérêt que vous sembliez portée aux
territoires ruraux
alors si l'opération de communication
était plutôt réussi la réalité
malheureusement présente un visage bien
différent
monsieur le premier ministre c'est de
matraques et continuellement les
territoires ruraux et surtout cesser de
faire le contraire de ce que vous
annoncez depuis 2012
vous avez massivement baisser les aides
aux communes alors que parallèlement
vous leur avez demandé toujours plus et
les communes rurales sont celles qui
sont les premières victimes
puisqu'elle ne dispose ni des ressources
en personnel il les moyens nécessaires
vous avez redéfini les critères des
zones d'éducation prioritaire dans la
majorité des cas ce sont les zones
rurales qui ont été exclus du dispositif
dans le même temps les services publics
se réorganisent manière élégante de dire
qu'il ferme et vous remplacer sa part de
la dématérialisation
mais dans les zones rurales avec un
numérique qui est aléatoire une
population âgée
ça ne simplifie rien la semaine dernière
vous avez carrément tenté de supprimer
les exonérations de cotisations
patronales dont bénéficient les
entreprises sur les territoires ruraux
maintenant dans votre projet de loi de
finance vous amputez de 50% les
ressources du fonds d'intervention pour
les services l'artisanat et le commerce
le fameux fisac
ce sont pourtant quasiment les seuls
dispositifs qui permettent de soutenir
le tissu économique de nos artisans et
commerçants sur nos territoires
vous nous dites que les territoires
ruraux se sentent oubliés mais c'est
vous qui les fragilise et par votre
politique ruralys id vous agissions
mépris des populations de nos campagnes
là où les auraient besoin plus que
jamais d'une discrimination positive en
leur faveur
je dis bien discrimination positive
alors monsieur le premier ministre je
vous demande avec insistance de mettre
en place une politique spécifique en
direction des territoires ruraux
merci la parole est à madame sylvia
pinel milices du logement de l'égalité
des territoires et la ruralité
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
jean-louis costes ne vous en déplaise ce
gouvernement a proposé à l'occasion des
différents comités interministériels de
nombreuses menu mesures pour corriger
justement les inégalités dans lesquelles
vous les aviez misé avant 2012 vous nous
parler monsieur le député des services
publics de l'école notamment mais ce que
je constate c'est qu'avec ce
gouvernement il ya davantage de zep dans
les territoires ruraux que précédemment
c'est la même chose avec les postes dans
l'éducation nationale c'est la même
chose dans les quartiers prioritaires de
la ville eux puisque avec nous il y à
des zones des contrats de ville qui sont
dans les territoires ruraux
je pourrais aussi vous parler des
maisons de services au public que nous
avons déployé que nous accélérons pour
enfin permettre d'avoir dans ces
territoires dans un même lieu des
services efficaces concentré pour donner
à nos concitoyens un égal accès à ces
services
c'est la même chose en matière de santé
ces maisons pluridisciplinaires ont été
augmentés je rappelle qu'en me en 2012
il y en avait 100 70 sur les territoires
demain il y en aura mille non monsieur
le député vous n'avez pas de leçons à
nous donner en matière d'aménagement du
territoire en matière de préoccupations
sur les territoires ruraux nous agissons
pour permettre justement à nos
concitoyens d'avoir les meilleurs
services alors que vous vous les avez
sacrifié avec des fermetures de classes
avec la fermeture de commissariat avec
la rgpp
vous n'avez pas à monsieur le député de
leçons à nous donner nous nous agissons
pour l'égalité des territoires de tous
les territoires de la république
merci madame la ministre
la parole est à mme ann m